one of the most uncontroversial pieces
of marriage advice I can give is that
it's never a good idea to focus
obsessively on the sins of the past even
though you know this is a common mistake
that people make in romantic
relationships most people understand
intellectually at least that it's not
productive or healthy to dwell on the
slights that your spouse has committed
in the past or the hurts they caused you
long ago in an argument as soon as you
utter the phrase oh yeah well remember
the time when you fill in the blank
you've likely destroyed any chance of
reaching any Mutual understanding or
worthwhile resolution once you bring
ancient history into discussion you've
stopped having a discussion and instead
turned it into a game of scoring points
everything is clouded Now by resentment
and grudges nothing is solved by your
decision to root through the past in
search of ammo to use against your
spouse in the present day you've only
created more problems without doing
anything to address whatever problem
started the argument in the first place
often you've taken some small disputes
and turned it into a much bigger deal
than it ever needed to be so one minute
you're squabbling because your wife gave
you a hard time about not using a
coaster when you put your drink down on
the coffee table the next minute you're
rehashing an argument dating back to
2009. this is why it's best to move on
from what has already happened and
already been hashed out and allow your
marriage to exist in the present moment
where you both have control over the
outcome
you cannot change the past you only have
power over the present and therefore to
some extent the future
now if this principle applies to
marriages so too does it apply to much
larger groups like say a nation
in fact it applies even more to Nations
than to marriages because at least the
infractions committed by your spouse in
the past were actually committed by your
spouse whereas the resentment that one
group in a country may carry against
another group in the country will often
stem from sins that were not committed
by anyone living today nor against
anyone living today
I mean it's one thing to hold someone's
past sins against them even that is
often counterproductive and unjust but
it's an entirely uh different thing a
much worse thing to hold someone's past
sins against someone else who had
nothing to do with them
yet this is exactly the situation that
the woke race Hustlers have tried
desperately and with horrifying success
to engineer
one of the reasons they've been so
successful in stirring up these
resentments keeping ancient wounds fresh
and still bleeding is that they start
the resentment building process very
early making sure to preach the
grievance gospel the children from a
very young age
case in point the latest Uber woke
episode from Disney's Uber woke children
show which is called the proud family
now for a little bit of background the
proud family was originally a kids show
on the Disney Channel back in the early
2000s it was canceled in 2005 and then
in 2022 it became uh just the latest
reboot that nobody needed nobody asked
for nobody wanted the rebooted proud
family which can be found now on Disney
plus promises to be louder and prouder
and it certainly fulfills at least half
of that promise
a clip from a recent episode has gone
viral over the past few days and in it
we are treated to what we're told is a
rap or a song about the Sinister origins
of the United States
and here it is
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane
and we weren't soldiers four million
strong fighting for America's freedoms
even though we remained America slave
built this country this of slaves
continue to build this slaves built this
country and we the descendants of slaves
in America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not its
own form slaves built this country not
only filled hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths musicians inventors
Washington Washington 40 acres and a
mule we'll take the 40 acres keep the
mill we made your families rent from the
southern plantation air to the northern
Banker to the New England ship owner the
founding fathers for my brother my
president current Senator the Illuminati
the New World Order of slaves built this
country we had Tubman Turner Frederick B
didn't they say Lincoln freed the slave
but slaves were meant and women and only
we can free ourselves emancipation is
not Freedom Jim Crow segregation
redlining Public Schools feeding private
prisons where we become slaves again as
we celebrate June 10th time our account
is still outstanding cause this country
was built on slavery which means slaves
built this country and we demand our 40
acres and a mule about that you can keep
the mule keep the 40. we're taking
freedom
[Applause]
just some nice wholesome children's
content so I'll stick with the bluey I
think
okay first of all
uh there's been some misinformation
about the content of that clip people
are saying that the Disney show featured
a you know an anti-American song
well that is anti-American but it's not
a song it's literally just shrill voices
chanting vacuous bumper sticker slogans
without rhyme or rhythm
which I guess you know sap doesn't
really separate it much from uh many
other pop songs but as Martin Luther
King would say we should judge woke
propaganda by not by its shrillness but
by its content the content here is
ridiculous on multiple levels levels so
let's let's go through them first and
most importantly
um and it is really necessary that we
emphasize that slaves did not build this
country
um this country was built over the
course of hundreds of years beginning
long before it was a country the
building started in the 1400s when the
first European explorers sailed across
treacherous and Uncharted Seas to
discover these lands it continued with
the European settlers in the 1500s and
1600s who built a life for themselves in
this unknown Wilderness facing Untold
threats and for many of them certain
death
this country was built by the colonists
and the American revolutionaries was
built by the Pioneers who expanded the
country from the East heading west out
into a hostile Wilderness occupied by
warring Indian tribes it was built by
War and conquest by Discovery by
diplomacy by industry
it was built and then nearly undone by a
civil war that killed 620 000 men then
built up again only to thrive once more
the country was built by the people who
made it into the world's great power in
the 20th century who won World Wars and
brought about peace and economic
Prosperity it was built by many people
over many centuries
and for a portion of that history some
people in some parts of the country own
slaves
that certainly is not enough to justify
the claim that the slaves built the
country
to make that claim is to erase nearly
everyone who really did build the
country it's to paper over America's
actual history with your
grievance-mongering nonsense
now if the mere historical fact of
slavery automatically means that the
country was built by slavery and forever
is indebted to slaves and their
descendants then of course the same must
be said about every nation on the planet
there is no race no people uh no Nation
anywhere in the world who does not
inherit the guilt of of slavery
if indeed the guilt of slavery can be
inherited
as I will never Tire of pointing out the
only thing that makes America's
relationship to slavery unique
is how comparatively quickly we
abolished it
and the lengths we went to abolish it
Western nations were patrolling the
oceans patrolling the oceans to shut
down the slave trade for for many years
while non-western Nations did everything
in the power to continue the slave trade
also
you notice something you notice how I
didn't use the word we
when talking about the people who did
build the country
okay a great many of the pioneers and
explorers and inventors and Warriors and
Statesmen and leaders Etc who built the
country were white
I mean most of them were white that's
that's that's the historical reality it
just is
and we certainly shouldn't be ashamed of
pointing that out or let ourselves be
shamed into not pointing it out or
denying it
yet as a white person I don't say we
because we would include me and I didn't
do any of those things I didn't come
here on the Mayflower I wasn't on the
Lewis and Clark expedition I didn't
fight in the Civil War I didn't storm
the beaches of Normandy
people who looked kind of like me did
but I didn't
so I don't take credit for their
achievements or claim their accolades
just as I don't pretend to have
experienced their suffering or felt
their pain
I stand at the end of this long line of
Triumph and sacrifice I am its
beneficiary
and so are you whatever your race
yet in that Disney song
that's not really a song
we hear the word we being used and this
is always the case with the race
hustlers they talk about the long ago
sufferings of people they never met and
who they missed meeting by a century and
a half and they say we and us
but no it's not a we are enough
situation because you were not enslaved
that didn't happen to you it just didn't
it may have happened to your ancestors
but if you go back a little further you
may just as well find that your
ancestors did it to others see this is
this is the problem of trying to claim
uh you know your entire lineage as if it
all happened to you is that you cannot
isolate this one particular moment in
your ancestry and take direct ownership
of it
speaking about it as if you were there
without owning all of the rest of your
ancestral history
a history that is guaranteed to include
brutality and impression inflicted on
others by your ancestors because
literally everyone's ancestors are
guilty of that
because that is the story of the human
race
not the white race the human race
so
alternatively
you can choose to stand in the present
on your own two feet
appropriating neither your ancestors
achievements nor their sufferings
nor their sins
you could be your own person
located in this moment of time
equipped with the freedom and luxury
given to you by those who died long
before you were born
it's your choice really you've got two
paths
and one gives you a chance at Living a
happy and successful life
the other keeps you wallowing
pathetically in self-pity obsessing over
resentments that don't belong to you
it's up to you
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]